good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so today we're going to learn
how to not take no for an answer
over to you Ryan Seacrest uh I think for
me like I say we're going to ask you I
am what I do I'm going to call them it
is absolute focus and determination and
a love for what you're pursuing and I
think may as I did what we pulled know a
lot and that know is something you you
can't always listen to like the loves
that will do that no can become it yet
but I think you've got to find out
something you love and pursue it with a
lot of focus so along your path of
success you're going to get a lot of
notes
you get a lot of people saying no no no
no no no no you can expect it and you
know what a lot of those nails are
justified because when you are first
starting something you're going to suck
your quality your output is going to
suck it's not going to be very good
because you don't have the talent you'll
have the skills you can put in the
effort yet and so you can expect people
to say no and it's kind of malicious no
it's not I want you to fail no you just
aren't providing them with enough value
yet and that's okay but if you have the
passion for what you want to do this is
a big dream this is the big goal of
yours and you have to push through this
is a great clip of Sylvester Stallone
where it says I love getting nodes
because I know just means a yes he sees
it as a challenge so the fact that he
got to know is a challenge for him to
want to go and push harder and go faster
and do more and prove prove to prove to
them but prove to himself that he that
is good enough that he can do it and so
I think it's really important that you
use negativity you use knows you use
criticism as a kick not down but forward
use a know as motivation to want to go
and do better and eventually get the yes
as opposed to
I suck I'm never going to get this this
is never going to work out and I think
it's really important to be hard on
yourself
but most people kick themselves down
instead of kicking themselves forward so
if you can learn to use your nose as
motivation to do better then you're on
the fast path to success
so the question today today is I'm
curious what was the most painful no
that you've gotten in your life I want
to know what it is they're going deep
today
leave it down the comments below and I
want you to as you write it out release
it so it doesn't hold you back anymore
I'm curious put it down the comment I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Edie
Reyes some creative new media inc as
thank you so much for picking a cup of
my book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the route so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event spread
[Music]
don't take no for an answer if you're
not working if it's not working well
that night it's not you it's the
audience blame it on the audience
because you've worked on Friday night it
ought to work on Saturday and if it
doesn't it's their fault
it's always simple but you know what it
works as a formula just go on and do the
Sunday night show and forget Saturday
night
keep kicking them in the nuts there's
something about an entrepreneur that is
somewhat sort of anti-establishment
somewhat disrespectful of the previous
generation and although catkin great
people - wrong way a little bit and it's
a really important element actually you
need to be passionate about what you
want to work on and don't take no for an
answer when when people out there are
giving you advice and saying no this
will never work I mean yeah you look at
eBay the idea that that in 1995 that you
could create something over the Internet
which is a brand new thing that nobody
you know was really using at the time
step for scientists and academics and
and it would be a place where strangers
can actually do business with one
another can actually like exchange
merchandise for money without ever
meeting you know and the notion of
people can actually buy and sell cars
over the internet and that's crazy right
it's totally crazy so in fact lots and
lots of people told me that was crazy
and I didn't you know I have to say I
didn't have this vision oh it's going to
take over the world it's going to be
this fantastic thing overnight I didn't
have that kind of delusion either but
but I did say you know there's something
there's something worth trying here it's
not it's not crazy